the jurogan experience this is from
1964.
what is it it's a foia risk request made
for the freedom of information freedom
of information act
for the file of barack hussein obama
senior as a graduate student in the
economics department at harvard
university
okay obama has passed his general exams
which indicates that on academic grounds
he is entitled to stay around here and
write his thesis
however they are going to try to cook
something
up to ease him out
all three that is all three harvard
people will have to agree on this
however they are planning on telling him
that they will not give him any money
and that he had better return to kenya
and prepare his thesis
at home which means he will never get
his phd
remember when they said take a break to
you this is
my alma mater
this is the thing i've been unc you know
there's this whole story about what
happened in my early life and why i
don't talk about it publicly and this is
why
this is interacting with your story
about joke thievery because
it's weird for a comic not to turn that
into a joke and it wasn't funny to you
in around i don't know 1988 1989 harvard
university told me
to remain in good standing in this
program you cannot live in massachusetts
why and i said what
how can you tell me where i can live and
where i can't live
it wasn't until somebody foied barack
obama's father and his file and i read
this story
that i realized that harvard has a
program for how it gets rid of people it
wants
to get rid of who are in good standing
there's a move it makes them move so
that they can't complete their thesis
why they want to do that with you um
probably because i'm as learning
disabled as the day is long
probably because i took a an unpopular
stance
that the equations that people were
working with called the donaldson theory
self dual equations were not the right
equations to be working with
and that we had somehow been assuming
that they were highly peculiar to
dimension
four and the the difficulty of the
equations which was what was giving us
all these great results
i had effectively gotten on the wrong
side i proposed some equations that were
i was told were insufficiently
non-linear never mind what that means
that in 1994
effectively the same equations took over
the entire field
whatever it was and this is like part of
the idea of reclaiming your own story
it was so crazy that a university would
tell me
what state i could live in
can i stop you so the people that are
telling you this
yeah they're operating on a pre-existing
solution to deal with people that they
find
undesirable or problematic if you fall
of them right so it's written somewhere
i don't know
or you know it's like people maintain
for example one way of
getting rid of a tenured professor
that's known
is is that you ask the person to report
on their research
and you load them up with teaching and
you give them a lousy office
and then eventually they'll just quit
because you make their life hell
so people know that there are these kind
of secret quiet ways to do the undoable
can i ask you this
what did you think about cornell west
being denied tenure from harvard
first of all i thought i assumed yeah he
already had it
i mean cornell west is this loved
intellectual when when i found out they
denied him tenure
i was like what the f what how do you
how do you deny cornell west tenure like
what is that
what did you think about that i first of
all am not
knowledgeable in that area i think of
him as a very
bright superstar of some sort of
part academic part social crossover high
impact
human yeah i was there when larry
summers was president
of um harvard when he
went out and said effectively too many
people are using the harvard label
and we're going to be reigning it in and
going back to
hard rigor and basics let me tell you
what people don't understand about
harvard harvard is two separate
structures
fused together one is about power
and one is about achievement and the two
of them are interlinked in a way that
cannot
be separated it without the achievement
harvard wouldn't have this kind of
glowing reputation that causes us to
sort of
uh over a history without the power
it wouldn't be able to attract the money
and it wouldn't be able to constantly
position itself
so through achievement it gets
enough cachet to wield power through the
power it gets the resources to buy
achievement
and this sort of thing is not understood
and i've been on both sides
of this thing like one of the things
that happened um
was that the boskin commission in 1996
tried to figure out how to cut social
security and raise taxes without getting
caught
because that's the third rail of
politics and what they said is if we
change the cpi the consumer price index
the way we measure inflation
because tax brackets are indexed and
because entitlement payments for social
security and medicare are indexed
if we claim that social security sorry
if we claim that inflation is overstated
by 1.1 percentage points we will gain a
trillion dollars in savings
and the public won't be able to object
to it because we're going to be just
adjusting a dial
we're going to say that this dial was
broken and we got some technocrats to
fix it
so they figured out we want to get a
trillion dollars over 10 years
they backed out that would require 1.1
percent overstatement
they broke into two teams one team came
up with 0.5
one team came up with 0.6 0.5 plus 0.6
equals 1.1
totally fictitious they got a trip
they got a proposal for a trillion
dollars that they were going to steal
effectively from social security
and they described this action
publicly robert gordon who was one of
the five boscon commissioners
um jamie could you bring up something
called boskin
wild versus mild
they brag about these things power wants
to explain
just how powerful it is
and you remember the scene in the big
short where they're talking to these
guys in florida and saying why are they
confessing
and somebody says they're not confessing
they're bragging it's a question of what
are you proud that you're able to do
all right so until robert gordon
did this powerpoint presentation we did
not have
to understand what happened to the work
that i did with my wife in economics
which is that we were trying to show how
you could actually compute
the consumer price index objectively
using gauge theory
the same year they were trying to figure
out how do we steal a trillion dollars
over 10 years
by doing funny games with the gauge
called inflation
do you do you find the wild versus the
mild yeah i did it's just loading a pdf
and it's like taking a bailed it's like
so this thing
perfect if you go to um
uh
go about five or six slides in
we'll see how that works okay
keep going five you'll find the word
somehow keep going okay dale said 1.1
percent
implies 1 trillion in social security
savings over 10 years
somehow our separate efforts came up
with the
1.1 percent bias number
in other words they came up with the
target
which is let's save trillion dollars and
then they came up with
we have to say it's overstated by 1.1 we
then broke into two groups and somehow
keyword we put the numbers together and
we got the target
this is academic malpractice practice in
the absolute extreme
when harvard was doing that it was
acting in its power capacity
and the way they did it was they buried
what i think is probably the best work
in
25 to 50 years in mathematical economics
that happened in the harvard economics
department
which is a second so-called marginal
revolution where we changed the calculus
underneath
all of economic theory so how does
something like this happen is there
a concerted effort did they get together
and they they have this idea
this is how we're going to five person
commission behind closed doors
that meets at the cousin's house of
somebody
on the commission in florida and in
another presentation lincoln florida
florida man in another presentation they
say
we solve this at the kitchen table of my
cousin's house in florida
you're just thinking like okay so it's
five guys
bob packwood and daniel patrick moynihan
a democrat and republican
got together picked five economists who
were willing to play the dirty game
the dirty game broke into two teams they
knew exactly what they had to do
they found the results to put them
together to put in front of congress
to put in front of the national academy
and then were they ever held accountable
for this no
there's an entire book called the
physics of wall street
in which my wife and i are chapter 10
and the epilogue
which it talks about they made weinstein
and milani go away
right so what i'm trying to talk to you
about is like
this this experience for me i've never
talked about this with anyone
i've never i mean i've talked to tons of
people privately
this is going to go out into the world i
was
you know you know this question like
what has eric weinstein ever done
i did that i did the marginal revolution
using engagement
that question is tim dillon joking
around yeah i know
he said what did he never created the
rotator he was very joking he was
[ __ ] around
that was the funny part about it he was
joking but he's saying that because he
knows you're brilliant
you understand the only reason why you
can say that if you were a loser
he couldn't say joe you don't need to
make me feel good about myself i know
but you brought it up again
no i'm saying something completely
different okay okay
i actually have been scared of this
question what question
that qu tim's question taken seriously
don't take it seriously i'm taking it
seriously okay
you're in a weird world okay here's
here's your weird world
you're in a world of serious
intellectual people you're damn straight
you're also hanging out with tim dillon
and me and i love it but it's
it's the problem is like you're you're
completing these two
things no joe i'm not that angry at tim
dillon it's not i'm not that angry do
you hear that you heard the word
you heard the word that that's a problem
you're not that angry at carlos mencia
i'm not angry at him at all i know and
i'm not i feel
sad i'm sad for tim dillon anyway
shouldn't be sad for tim
wait wait wait wait wait he's one of the
most important comedians of ours okay
how dare you i it took it gave me a
moment to rip
to reflect and i realized something
which is i don't want to talk about this
[ __ ]
publicly i don't want to say dale
jorgensen is the guy who buried
one of the most important innovations in
economics but yeah you just did i just
did
and that's what i've just done that's
what i i realized by reviewing your
history
and revealing your seven years away from
the store
i don't want to be associated with dale
jorgensen i don't care about him
i want to be associated with gage
theoretic economics
i see what you're saying and what i
realized is i don't want to be
associated
with the [ __ ] that happened over
something called the cyborg whitten
equations
what i just handed you one of the
reasons i've held it back is that it
very clearly gives an alternate
definition
alternate motivation and derivation of
the equations that revolutionized gage
theory which is what i was thinking
about
in around 1987 1988
and i've lived afraid of my own story
because
it's such an ugly story the story of a
guy who is not allowed to attend his own
thesis defense to
any academician you hear like what do
you mean you weren't allowed to
you present your thesis no no no i was
not allowed in the room of my own thesis
so this is why harvard wanted you to
move out of state
harvard and i got into a thing because
of that
because of a conflict because also of
this
because of geometric unity because i
said i want to do
physics and i have an idea about how
physics goes
and to be brutally honest i was
technically
underpowered i am technically
underpowered i was conceptually
amazing i was very creative very
generative
tons and tons of great ideas i think i'm
being honest on both fronts
technically underpowered okay
i couldn't accept myself in this world
of like
you know if you play classical music
everybody's technically brilliant
there's no technically weak people in
classical music
i was like a guy was like it was like
john lee hooker in the orchestra
of you know the cleveland symphony
orchestra on one string and a guitar
playing with some weird syncopated
rhythm
boom boom boom boom boom boom gonna
shoot your head down yeah exactly
mom said let that daddy say let that boy
boogie woogie it's in him and it's got
to come out
that thing i'm scared of why because
it's my history because i don't want to
go back into it i don't want to go back
to being the guy begging dale jorgensen
oh
pretty pleased with sugar on top let me
innovate your entire field
i don't want to go back to the harvard
department and say the words clifford
taubs
you had gary tabbs on your program
mm-hmm
clifford tobbs was the guy who told me i
had to move out of state
clifford is a gary yeah he's a brother
yeah he was the guy who held the secret
seminar
and the thing is is that i'm not against
the person in the story
i don't want to have it i don't want to
be involved with him
i want him to go and be successful and
have a good career but my story
when i put forward those equations and
he said they're insufficiently
non-linear
and he said self-duality doesn't have
anything to do with
spinners because if it did nigel
hitchens would have told us
okay nigel would have told us he didn't
say hitchens he was wrong
and then when i gave him the opportunity
he didn't say you know what eric
weinstein brought these equations up and
i told him no
and that thing is like something i've
held open the door he's now in his
mid 60s i was like
you really couldn't just say maybe i
screwed up
you should go kick his ass no why i'm
choking
i know
[Laughter]
i thought you were going to cry 30
seconds ago do you have a tissue no
somewhere then that was over there but
that's
this is the thing i've been running what
i realized through tim
it wasn't a question of being angry at
him really i've been running away from
my own story
just the way i don't like you associated
with i haven't mentioned the guy who
was the joke thief in this entire time
yeah i understand what you're saying
right it's like why are you and he
entangled in a story because he has
nothing to do with your life
it's okay it doesn't bother me that i'm
entangled with them
what bothers me that i'm entangled with
this stuff
um i know what you're saying
because i want to be joyous i want to
produce
positive things that uplift us to give
us a hope
of breaking like the einsteinian speed
limit you know if this is wrong
i want to know i think it's right
i think with all my flaws and all my
failings and being 25 years out of the
field
i believe that this story is going to be
fixed by people who are trying to shoot
it down and say holy [ __ ]
i think there's something here well now
we're going to know right i think i'm
hoping you released it today
on geometricunity.org
and go to pull that up jamie.com and you
can watch all the videos that we didn't
show you
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience